with morning temperatures in the single
digits people waited outside to get
water from emergency filling stations in
Keys
we can stand in line they the Russians
says the 74 year old wouldn't be able to
handle this
attacks on critical infrastructure in
the capital and right across the country
prompted early morning rocket warning
sirens and a flurry of activity for
utility Crews uh experts right now
working and we hope it's we fix the
problem in the next couple of hours it
seems as fast as repairs are made
systems are knocked out Ukraine's prime
minister noted the attacks hit 18 mostly
energy related facilities in harkiv one
such strike left people sitting in the
dark on Metro trains the latest barrage
of missile strikes followed a weekend
Ukrainian drone attack on Russian
vessels in the Black Sea video appearing
to show the strike popped up on social
media Russia reported damage to one
warship the vessels according to Russia
were in the Crimean Port as a part of
the deal to guarantee the safety of
shipments carrying Ukrainian grain
fertilizers and other food products
Russia has pulled out of the that
agreement prompting concerns about food
security Moldova meanwhile has been
dragged into the conflict the Deputy
Prime Minister tweeted that debris from
a missile intercepted by Ukraine caused
damage in a Northern border Village
riding the Shockwave shattered windows
on several residential houses he added
the appalling strike on critical
infrastructure reverberates Beyond
Ukraine's borders and pose a threat
direct to moldova's energy and human
security
Norwegian officials meanwhile say
Russia's invasion of Ukraine poses the
most serious security situation in
Europe in decades as a precaution Norway
put its military on a raised alert level
effective November 1st Crystal gemancing
Global News London